- [Instructor] So we
have two cylinders here.
Let's say we know that they
have the exact same volume
and that makes sense because it looks like
they have the same area of their base
and they have the same height.
Now what I'm going to
do is start cutting up
this left cylinder here
and shifting things around.
So if I just cut it in two
and take that bottom cylinder,
that bottom half and shift it a bit,
have I changed its volume?
Well, clearly I have
not changed its volume.
I still have the same volume.
The combined volume of both
of these half cylinders,
I could say, are equal
to the original cylinder.
Now what if I were to cut it up even more?
So let me cut it up now into three.
Well, once again I still haven't
changed my original volume.
It's still the same volume as original
and I just cut it up into thirds.
And if I shift them around a little bit
I'm not changing the volume.
And I could keep doing that.
I could cut it up into a bunch of them.
Notice, this still has
the same original volume,
I've just cut it up into
a bunch of sections.
I've cut it horizontally
and now I'm just shifting things around,
but that doesn't change the volume.
And I can do it a bunch of times.
This looks like some type of
poker chips or gambling chips
where I can have my original cylinder
and now I've cut it horizontally
into a bunch of these, I
guess you could say chips
but clearly it has the
same combined volume.
I can shift it around a bit
but it has the same volume.
And this leads us to
an interesting question
and it's actually a principle
known as Cavalieri's principle,
which is if I have two figures
that have the same height
and at any point along that height,
the cross-sectional area is the same,
then the two figures have the same volume.
Now how does what I just say
apply to what's going on here?
Well, clearly both of these
figures have the same height
and then at any point here,
wherever I did the cuts,
at the same point on
this original cylinder,
well, my cross-sectional
area is going to be the same
because it's going to be the same area
as the base in the case of this cylinder
and so it meets Cavalieri's principle.
But Cavalieri's
principle's nothing exotic.
It comes straight out of common sense.
I can just do more cuts like this
and you can see that I have,
you can see a more continuous
looking skewed cylinder
but this will have the same
volume as our original cylinder.
When I shift it around like this,
it's not changing the volume.
And that's not just true for cylinders.
I could do the exact same argument
with some form of a prism.
Once again they have the same volume.
I could shift, I could
cut the left one in half
and shift it around,
doesn't change its volume.
I could cut it more
and shift those around,
still doesn't change the volume.
So Cavalieri's principle
seems to make a lot
of intuitive sense here.
If I have two figures
that have the same height
and at any point along that height,
the cross-sectional area is the same,
then the figures have the same volume.
So these figures also
have the same volume.
And I could do it with interesting things
like, say, a pyramid.
These two pyramids have the same volume
and I were to cut the left pyramid
halfway along its height and
shift the bottom like this,
that doesn't change its volume.
And I can keep doing that
with more and more cuts.
And 'cause at any point here,
these figures have the same height
and at any point on that height,
the cross-sectional area is the same,
and so they have the same volume.
But once again it is intuitive.
And it goes all the way to
the case where you have,
you could view it as a continuous
pyramid right over here
that has been skewed.
So no matter how much you skew it,
it's gonna have the same
volume as our original pyramid
'cause they have the same height.
And the cross-sectional area
at any point in the height
is going to be the same.
We can actually do this with any figure.
So these spheres have the same volume.
I could cut the left one in half,
halfway along its height
and shift it like this.
Clearly, I'm not changing the volume.
And I could make more cuts like that.
And clearly it has still the same volume.
And this meets Cavalieri's principle
because they have the same height
and the cross section at
any point along that height
is going to be the same.
So even though I can cut that
one up and I can shift it,
it looks like a different type of object,
a different type of thing,
but they have the same
height and cross sections
at any point are the same area,
so we have the same volume,
which is a useful thing to know
not just to know the principle
but hopefully this video helps you gain
some of the intuition for
why it makes intuitive sense.